what's the barial list
[__] um you know the
Jacka um The
Jacka M Dre for sure E40 San
Quinn and I mean bro you got to give two
shortest Pro get too short yeah yeah
it's crazy I I feel like people who
aren't from the bay will never quite uh
understand M Dre or san Quinn San or san
Quinn or even The Jacka for sure the
jagga that's my number one Bay Area you
know I'm one of his biggest fans but the
San Quinn's probably one of the best
rappers out this at the bay I think out
the West Coast he just never got a
chance to shine like that on a very very
major level but like Quinn still got
heat to this day yeah yeah for sure now
I think it's crazy cuz like I had that I
had that talk with
um uh somebody else from the bay that I
won mentioned but we're we're kind of
talking about how like like
I understand why M Dre is important I
understand you know I I also understand
from what a lot of people told me that
people didn't really in terms of the
streets [__] with him and like like at
least the his thiz era [__] until he
passed it was more like some Berkeley
[__] and then once he pass people kind
of really truly appreciated gravitated
to him yeah what he did you know what
I'm saying um all right man [__] hey
before we go can you give me the last
time we hung out you gave me
um
OG uh burner in the in the
uh I forget what happened you almost you
afraid you were going to get robbed in
the mountains of Humble County that [__]
went super viral let's let's dive back
15 years 20 years burn give me the
another random just Story Time with
Burner give me a crazy story about a
situation that might have been dicey
back in the
day um it could have been in Humble
County it could have been in the Streets
of San Francisco give me give me a
little anecdotal little tidbit man
before we go
well I guess a good one would be
um I let someone handle something for me
one time and uh you know I just I felt
in my gut that it wouldn't be the right
move but I said bro like be very
attentive these guys are kind of like
these guys are kind of Shifty and I
don't think they're going to Rob You by
gunpoint but I feel like something's
going to go wrong with it you know I'm
going to let you handle this cuz I'm not
around but like be very attentive to
what happens he's like for sure I got
you so he goes to meet up with this guy
in the hotel and he gives him the bags
and a duffel bag and the guy gives him
the money the money is vacuum sealed and
um you know it looks right hundreds on
top and whatever and there was two
vacuum seal bags and kind of made a joke
like what you don't trust me want to
count here you really want to count it
all here I got [__] to do I got to move
I got to go boxy he up and get him out
of here D was like yeah you know he's
like bro at least bust open one you can
count it real quick and and the dude
opened up for him the vacuum SE back and
hand him a stack and counted through the
whole stack it's all 100s boom boom boom
cool put it back in he's like bro I got
to go I got to move you know what I mean
boom my boy takes off gets to where he's
going opens up the vacuum seals and the
rest of all the stacks are just 100 on
top of all ones o and I'm like he calls
me and tells me like bro you really let
this man pull out the stack and count it
for you like I mean he didn't count it
for him but you really let him open that
pack up and give you one you knew was
probably like you let him give you the
right corner stack you didn't go through
anything else he's like bro he was
moving so fast it was nervous it was
just seem Shady he was opening up the
pack and started smelling the room I
just want to get out of there with all
that bread and I was worried about
getting robbed when I left I'm like but
you worried about getting robbed when
you left but you got robbed right there
he's calling the dude's phones for
dude's phones out service and how much
how much money are we talking I don't
even remember at the time it was like
probably like 16 years ago or something
like that but I just know my boy got
[__] big time and it fell on him I'm
like bro you were there to handle it you
were there to count the bread I told you
what to do you didn't do it so that's on
you you got to eat that [__] L yeah
he never pay me back for it but yeah
that was a random one so for all them
bad boys out there if someone comes with
a neatly stack of hundreds all flattened
out perfect in the vacuum so go through
it yeah you should never just take the
vacuum seal of money just open it up
make sure it's there it's actually money
coun for already somewhere doing a deal
it's I mean you're already invested in
this situation counted out so you know
that's just a good old story that
happened someone pulled a slick one on
my little homie and my little homie is
supposed to pay me back but he did not